>>> NEW TONIGHT, THE MOTHER OF
CAPTURED AMERICAN ALEX DRUEKE,
SPEAKING WITH HER SON TODAY AS
HE IS HELD IN UKRAINE FOR 19
DAYS NOW.
ALEX WAS CAPTURED ALONG WITH
ANDY WYNN ON JUNE 11th, WHILE
FIGHTING FOR UKRAINIAN FORCES
OUT FRONT OF KHARKIV.
BUNNY, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE.
REALLY GOOD TO SEE YOU.
HOW DID ALEX SOUND TODAY?
>> MOST OF THE PHONE CALL
SOUNDED VERY BUSINESS-LIKE.
HE HAD INFORMATION THAT HE
NEEDED TO TELL ME AND THEN HE
HAD A CHANCE TO RELAX A LITTLE
BIT AND TALK ABOUT HIS DOG.
>> WHAT DID HE SAY ABOUT HIS DOG
THIS TIME?
I KNOW THAT SEEMS TO BE A TOPIC
HE LIKES TO RETURN TO.
>> WELL, ALEX DOESN'T HAVE ANY
CHILDREN, AND HIS DOG IS MY
GRANDDOG.
IN FACT, I HAVE A T-SHIRT WITH
MY GRAND CHILDREN AND DIESEL IS
LISTED ON IT, SO IT IS A DOG
THAT'S VERY SPECIAL TO ALEX AND
HE HAD HIS YEARLY CHECK-UP
YESTERDAY AND ALEX WANTED TO
KNOW HOW IT WENT AND HOW MUCH
DIESEL WEIGHED AND, FOR YOUR
INFORMATION, 109 POUNDS.
>> GOOD, GOOD TO KNOW.
HOW DID HE -- IT'S WONDERFUL TO
HEAR
[ LAUGHTER ]
LAUGHTER AND HAPPINESS IN YOUR
VOICE, BECAUSE HOW CAN YOU BE
ANYTHING BUT SCARED AND
TERRIFIED FOR WHAT YOUR SON IS
FACING AND HIS CIRCUMSTANCES.
DID HE SOUND GOOD, DID HE SOUND
WELL?
>> HE SOUNDED VERY FIRM, HE
SOUNDED BUSINESS-LIKE.
BECAUSE HIS CAPTORS, NOT WHAT HE
CALLS THEM, JUST SAY "THEY" BUT
HIS CAPTORS WANTED HIM TO GET
OUT THE NEWS THAT THEY ARE VERY,
VERY EAGER TO NEGOTIATE ALEX AND
ANDY'S RELEASE.
>> YOU WERE ABLE, ON THAT EXACT
POINT, YOU SPOKE TO THE STATE
DEPARTMENT TODAY.
WHAT ARE THEY TELLING YOU?
>> WELL, THEY ARE TELLING ME
THAT ALL COMMUNICATION CHANNELS
FOR NEGOTIATIONS ARE OPEN AND
THAT THEY ARE, YOU KNOW, READY
TO TALK ABOUT IT OR, YOU KNOW,
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE THEY HAVE
EVERYTHING ON THE BALL AND, OF
COURSE, I'M NOT PRIVY TO WHAT IS
GOING ON BEHIND THE SCENES.
BUT BECAUSE OF THE WAY THEY HAVE
TRUSTED US, TO TELL US
INFORMATION AS WE GO ALONG, I
FEEL LIKE I CAN TRUST THEM NOW
WHEN THEY SAY THEY ARE WORKING
TOWARDS THE RELEASE IN ANY WAY
THAT THEY POSSIBLY CAN.
I DID STRESS TO ALEX, I KNOW
THAT THERE WERE PEOPLE IN THE
ROOM WITH HIM, BECAUSE I ASKED,
WAS HE ALONE?
I STRESSED TO THEM THAT THIS IS
A VERY DELICATE, DIPLOMATIC
SITUATION.
THE U.S. DOES NOT RECOGNIZE THE
DPR AS A COUNTRY.
WE DON'T HAVE DIPLOMATIC
RELATIONS WITH THEM, SO IT MAKES
IT VERY TRICKY TO TRY TO DO ANY
KIND OF NEGOTIATION ONE-ON-ONE.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, A LOT OF WHAT
ALEX AND I WERE TALKING ABOUT
WAS MORE FOR THE BENEFIT OF WHAT
HIS CAPTORS NEEDED TO UNDERSTAND
ABOUT OUR GOVERNMENT AND HOW IT
WORKS.
>> JUST AS WHAT YOU'RE
DESCRIBING, AND WHAT YOU ARE
TRYING TO CONVEY TO HIS CAPTORS,
IT'S REALLY JUST A REMINDER OF
WHAT UNIMAGINABLE CIRCUMSTANCES
YOU HAVE FOUND YOURSELF IN AND
WHAT YOUR POOR SON FOUND HIMSELF
IN, OF COURSE.
DID THE CONVERSATION, DID THE
CONVERSATION WITH ALEX -- HOW
DID IT MAKE YOU FEEL?
AS A MOTHER, DID IT BRING YOU
HOPE?
DOES IT BRING YOU COMFORT?
>> YES, IT BRINGS ME HOPE.
IT BRINGS ME COMFORT.
IT BRINGS ME A BIT OF TORMENT,
BECAUSE I'D RATHER BE TALKING TO
HIM FACE-TO-FACE AND BE ABLE TO
REACH OUT AND TOUCH HIM AND KNOW
THAT HE'S SAFE.
I ALSO AM NOT SURE HOW FREE HE
IS TO TELL ME ABOUT CONDITIONS,
OR HOW MUCH HE MIGHT BE WANTING
TO SHELTER ME.
I HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT.
SO, YOU KNOW, I STILL HAVE A LOT
OF QUESTIONS ABOUT IT, BUT
OVERALL, IT'S WONDERFUL TO TAKE
THAT PHONE CALL AND HEAR HIS
VOICE.
IT SOUNDS STRONG.
HE IS HAPPY TO HEAR MY VOICE.
AND I HAVE A CHANCE TO REMIND
HIM HOW MUCH I LOVE HIM, AND
THAT I'M DOING EVERYTHING --
EVERYTHING -- THAT I CAN TO GET
HE AND ANDY RELEASED SAFELY.
>> AND HEARING THAT RESOLVE AND
COMMITMENT IN YOUR VOICE I'M
SURE MEANS EVERYTHING TO HIM IN
THIS MOMENT.
AND THERE'S ALSO ANDY.
I UNDERSTAND ALEX CAN'T SEE ANDY
BECAUSE THEY'RE BOTH BEING HELD
IN SOLITARY CONFINEMENT, AT
LEAST HE BELIEVES, BUT ANDY HAS
NOT CALLED HIS FAMILY SINCE THEY
WERE CAPTURED.
WAS ALEX ABLE TO TELL YOU
ANYTHING ABOUT THAT?
DOES HE HAVE A SENSE OF WHY THAT
IS?
>> NO, IN FACT, I WAS ABLE TO
TELL ALEX SOMETHING ABOUT ANDY.
THERE ARE VIDEOS THAT WERE
RELEASED.
I SAW THEM YESTERDAY.
I THINK THAT'S WHEN THEY WERE
RELEASED AND I SAID I SAW A
VIDEO OF YOU AND YOU CUT YOUR
HAIR.
AND ALEX SAID YES, HE HAD, AND I
SAID I SAW ANDY, TOO.
HOW RECENT WAS THAT VIDEO?
AND HE SAID TWO DAYS AGO.
AND
I SAID ANDY LOOKED TIRED BUT
GOOD.
AND ALEX SAID, I'M